with number one about Consulting and
this is likely the thing that I hear
most frequently when people talk badly
about consultants and this is that
Consultants just write down what other
people on the client side tell them to
write down anyway so pretty much
implying that the results of the project
are already clear are already defined
from the beginning of the project so
what is my view on that and in general
personally I consider this perspective
to be flawed I never experienc a
situation where at the beginning of a
project it was clear what the result was
supposed to be I never was in a meeting
with a partner or any other senior
Personnel of a consulting firm telling
the team explaining to the team that
this is now the task this is what we
need to write on piece of paper this is
what the client wants